and in some ways i kind of like the
fact that if you slow it down you'll
get some more from it yeah that's
what canadian lad does so well yeah
everything's slow i watch this at point one
percent point zero zero zero one speed and i
learned nothing i learned that i could speed this
up a little bit and get the same amount of context
i learned that if you slow things down
enough everything sounds like whale song
what's going on there reject nation we are going
to watch today from new rock stars doctor strange
to easter eggs and breakdown the man ea foss
follow him on twitter you can subscribe and
click the notification bell for our channel but
more importantly leave a like they'd be very much
appreciated let's see what's going on right now
people welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness a movie that teaches
us all a valuable lesson about what happens when
marvel fans dream too big the scarlet witch will
break all your toys and make you watch director's
damn game writes the mcu's first true horror film
that also rewrites the rules of the mcu in so many
cool ways so let's break down this movie scene by
scene for the incredible attention to detail and
deeper layer of meaning that you might have missed
so the marvel studios title card in this movie
has been updated the shots that previously showed
moments have all been replaced with wanda's
scarlet witch power up and one division and
various shots of doctor strange from the 2016 film
infinity war and end game the final shot on the
m of marvel studios is strange's final scene in
the 2016 film but in the inner top of the r was
wanda's team up with her family yeah i got that
so this is actually the first time anything from
a disney plus title has made it into the title
card just proving how important wanda's experience
with their kids from that show is to this movie
also fun to note that behind wanda's family in
that shot is the west view cinema with oz the
great and powerful plane a 2013. also directed
by sam raimi oz and its witches definitely have
parallels in this movie story i'll get to that
later but the film opens in the gap junction
as defender strange races with american chavez
toward the book of ashanti fleeing this ribbony
monster marked with runes later we learn a puppet
marionetted by the scarlet witch america chavez
is a young multiverse hopper from the comics who
comes from the utopian parallel and you'll notice
how the opening words exchanged in this film are
in spanish underlining chavez's role as the first
latina superhero of the mcu as well as the first
lgbtq plus superhero her star emblazoned jacket
has a pride flag pin on it i actually think it'd
be pretty cool to get a solo america chavez film i
know that's not the thing that's really in demand
right now but i really found myself craving more
from her character the second time watching this
and seeing the world where she comes from no no
get a lot of lesbian love how cool would that
be to get in a marvel cinematic universe movie
and then cut out of the chinese cut yeah yeah
billion dollars plus you know i just think zoshi
gomez is such a great job and i would like to see
more of her or young avengers whatever honor
jacket has also written the phrase amores
amore spanish for love is love now the book of
the shanti also from the comics is a book of
positive counterspells sharing its name with the
seal of vishanti the shape formed by the window
of the sanctum sanctorum now the gap junction is
later described as the space between universes
and here it's presented as a sacred church-like
plane but now in ruins as if the damage already
done to the fabric of the multiverse entitles like
loki and spider-man no way home have taken a toll
on this place and this week marvel had kevin
feige confirmed that the multiversal crises of
those titles directly set the stage for the crisis
of this film see i just wish the the movie itself
acknowledged that directly in some way that way
it really felt like more of multiverse of madness
yeah absolutely you know that would be more
elevated and felt versus having to look out
for what kevin feige saying in interviews they
connect if you read that quote the platform with
the book on it has 16 walkways converging out from
it many of them broken off a cool way of showing
how all the universes that connected this are all
backdoors leading to this one book but many of
those universes and those pathways have crumbled
and eroded now defender strange seems at first
like the gallant to the goofus that we've known
multilingual only using defensive spells like
freezing and binding hair tied back in a ponytail
like the chillest barista ever but we learned
in this case america he says this is the only way
and in the grand calculus of the multiverse your
sacrifice before it gets cut off both of these
lines being callbacks linking this strange variant
to our doctor strange who after sacrificing the
time stone to thanos infinity war told tony stark
there was no other way and recently in spider-man
no way home told these exact words to peter parker
in relation to the deaths of norman osborne and
the rest being necessary in the grand calculus of
the multiverse their sacrifice means infinitely
more than their wives you know that's something
that marvel can often sneak up on you without
realizing because i've had this talk with a few
people actually can you define for me clear-cut
what is strange's character arc in this film like
what are some of the lessons that he's learned
some are more obvious than others something that
kind of flew over my head up until this breakdown
was how this arc is a progressive from infinity
war to no way home to what we're getting
here now versus establishing just where he's
at now but kind of like what they did with hulk
having his arc appear through several films and
i didn't even really register like oh this has
been occurring from the start of infinity war
this idea of him having to like willing to
sacrifice lives that's just one layer to the
ark i think do you know where i'm getting at do
you do do you i don't understand what so really
no i no absolutely do actually i think it's a
really nice thing that they've been it's a nice
thing with strangely this is a really nice really
nice lesson it's nice to learn to not kill america
yeah you know it's always a good day when
you don't kill america but a fatally wounded
defender strange tumbles with america through
a star portal and the camera work of sam raimi
and director of photography john matheson rotate
in a really fun way rotating raby hot head shot
having seen all of this as a dream now this movie
actually defines all of dreams as us seen into the
lives of our multiversal selves a concept that
has been explored in real world metaphysics but
in the mcu poses some interesting questions were
the nightmares wanda gave the avengers and age of
ultron visions of other universes tony's dream
that he told pepper about in a video last night
i dreamt we had a kid so real we named him after
your eccentric uncle uh what was his name morgan
of course they would eventually have a
kid named morgan so tony's dream there
likely was an alternate universe so strange
glances over his broken wristwatch the one
from the 2016 film given to him by christine
palmer and broken by robbers outside comtaj a
watch face that he left broken to reflect the
unhealable wound of his hands and his mastery
of the mystic and mental over the physical in
this film the watch symbol evolves to symbolize
his forever broken relationship with christine
and how that's actually okay strange uses magic
to tie his tie a reminder that his hands are
still damaged from his accident in the 2016
film his hands truly are his unhealable wound at
the wedding he passes this mom with two sons just
a little echo of the conflict that he's about
to face with wanda trying to reunite with him
oh they're just background actors whatever and
reveals he too dusted in the blip and lost two
cats and oh yeah a brother too he ponders if there
could have been any other path strange might have
taken infinity war and by having to think about
this strange faces that his sacrifice play at the
time stone while it eventually led to the avengers
being able to fix things sort of in end game it
also left survivors living with the emotional toll
of that conflict and in wanda's case thanos using
that same time stone to render her heartbreaking
killing of vision meaningless strange turns a
glass of water into wine freaking jesus over here
also reminding us of when he refilled thor's beer
mug in ragnarok really the best way to use magic
if you ask me strange apologizes saying that he
made sacrifices to protect christine but that he's
glad she's happy really this whole movie is a tug
of war between sacrifice on one hand and happiness
on the other our heroes begin this movie thinking
that sacrifice comes at the cost of personal
happiness but must learn by the end of the film
that sacrificing what we think we want is really
how we find deeper fulfillment and inner peace
but it also seems to have this weird interesting
layer that happiness is not something you just
achieve it's not a destination that you just
stay at ever and it's not something that like
a huge goal can create for you yeah because that
question is posed often that's what makes sinner
sir strange go sinister and his story when
according to him when he says christine asked
him like are you happy and then he went home
and he's like no i'm not encouraging time to
collide all the universes together but by the end
of the movie he's talking to wong and he's saying
like he thinks saving the universe would make you
happy but i'm not yeah then he goes encourages him
ungrateful slime strangers commotion outside
and tugs his red pocket square revealing it
as his cloak of levitation and he would not
believe the [__] i got in trailer breakdowns
for theorizing that pocket square was his cloak i
love how he summons it in freaking yeah yeah you
know tony stark being caught by the mark
7 armor while falling in the avengers film
now this beast is initially invisible similar
to how the supernatural forces of moon knight
are initially invisible to onlookers but strange
decloaks it trivial the squid monster of gargantos
a lesser-known comics foed and namor the
submariner and i love how the animators
use his single eye to characterize him surprised
when strange dismantles the bust his eyelid crease
to show anger his pupil dilation when strange
severs is tentacle and of course a lot of great
details when the eye is about to get skewered
now danny's a lot of personality this whole film
with a madcap feverish energy and here he uses
some great horns now i love the music so much
so good so sinister evoking mussorgy's
night on bald mountain yes there you go
the back of the bus has an ad for la llave coffee
unlock a better day like are they being spanish
for key a hint at strange's upcoming quest to use
his watch to unlock the back door and also this
spanish speaker superhero being the key to his
multiverse also nearby is an ad for the magic
of celestial team and with strange jumps
on the taxi there's a sign behind him for
a real brand which might be a nod to
stan lee whose real name was stanley
no my definitely tribute to him with stanley's
pizza wong shows up to try to restrain gargantos
gargantus uses one of his suction cuffs to detach
his canal maybe showing how he does have some
defensive moves against the kinds of attacks namor
might hit him with he scales the building sam
raimi evoking his sequence with doc ock scaling
the building in 2004 spider-man 2. honestly right
when he jumped off the ledge and just started
going into new york that's when i had the thought
of this feels like sam raimi's spider-man
yeah like this feels like doctor strange
on the other side of new york while spider-man is
fighting something more grounded he's equipping
is dealing with this but it felt like this is the
rainy world at that moment his new york world and
i love that and just something like this even more
so there was a moment that eric did not point out
where a guy is on a motorcycle and he crashes into
gargantos and the second time around i was going
what was i thinking i'm gonna save it i'm
gonna sacrifice myself for everyone to
make you proud mom and dad my life's been
leading to this one back at the wedding
behind christine and charlie is a cameo
by this movie screenwriter michael waldron
oh [__] i saw his name in the credits so i was
wondering where i learned garganto's in the eye
and then pumps that eye out with its connective
tissue looking a lot like sam raimi's hilarious
flying eyeball in evil dead 2. strange and wong
mentioned their recent deal with spider-man and
no way home and america asks if he shoots webs
out of his butt harvesting tom holland peter and
andrew garfield peter were both pretty grossed out
by how timmy mcguire peter's webbing multiverse
does it come out of anywhere else only only the
wrists now wait didn't strange and wong forget
about everything after that movie's final memory
wipe spell well not exactly they only forgot who
peter parker is they still remember a masked
spider-man being part of their history like
notice here they never call him peter parker
and aren't really sure how his webbing works
just further proof that he's just back to being
a stranger to them but they still know of a
spider-man existing in this universe wait a minute
that scene there i didn't even question that at
the time i know i just go with the flow hey bug
themed heroes i wasn't even like no people forget
the way he recounts his multiverse experience
dealing with spider-man would he remember about
multiverse with spider-man just every moment where
it's a ruler parker had his mask off yeah it's a
really patchy memory and it's only those moments
that's literally how it's such a big question now
that's a big question mark because yeah it's
like the spell says you race peter parker from
everyone's mind so that must just leave these like
weird gappy spider-man recollections because the
multiverse thing all happened because he was
literally interacting with tom holland because
he was like i want to go to college none of that
retains maybe he remembers all those things as
just him talking to a masked spider-man now maybe
that's how it works could he talk to those other
spider-men who didn't have masks on whatever but
he doesn't know who any of them are now either
that's true because he doesn't know any peter's
park i don't i think that would be as good as
we can't figure this out ever america shows them
defender strange's corpse on the sanctum roof and
strange buries him up there saying that he's
quote buried worse and i'm dying to know who
else is in strange's life that he has buried and
wear now they realize that the magical friends
was witchcraft and so we returned to wanda's
kitchen in west view using the same one division
episode two bewitched inspired intro music which
is composed by the lopez's in this kitchen they
have a hamster cage labeled max maybe short for
maximoff replacing poor sparky the dog billy and
tommy return here back to wearing the same red and
green colors as wiccan and speed do in the comics
wanda wakes up from this dream alone in her
bed and i love how the warm golden color tone
of the room shifts to a colder desaturation just
another example of dreams being windows into her
alternate selves then wanda prunes branches in
an apple orchard just really cool symbolism here
she says apples eventually as they haven't yet
borne fruit as her efforts to produce a light with
her sons has also been fruitless she prunes arabic
branches paralleling the ways he who remains and
the tva would prove it yeah a good cause for the
multiverse you know like how one is using the
dark hole to x off universes without her sons in
them and these being apples definitely reminds us
of the poisoned apple of the witch queen of snow
white which actually gets a cameo later on in this
film gotta say i bet the production design and
michael walter when they watch this video you're
gonna be like wow this guy's making it sound
like we really thought about that i'm impressed
by the things we accidentally put in here i just
needed to have her prune stuff you know he has an
activity you can't have talking heads in a seat
yeah i just said hey have some business i don't
know give her some shears it's a veneer let it
be you know everything in the film is intentional
that's what they teach you in school strange says
the flowers smell real and wanda claims she put
reality warping witchcraft behind her after
westview yet even here the simulation seems
real enough to nearly full strange they chat
what do you know about the multiverse this had
his theories he believed it was dangerous and
then she drops the branches in a crate labeled
volkers or bjolkers now in the comics wendell
volker is an academic who along with reed richards
discovers that baron zemo has traveled back in
time in a 2007 thunderbolt story no maybe this
is like the hovian estate that wanda has overtaken
temporarily somewhere close to that mountain cabin
we saw her in wanda says there are other avengers
and strange mentions the archer with the mohawk
and several bug-themed crime fighters of course
referring to hawkeye ant-man the wasp hawkeye
doesn't have a mohawk anymore no bring back the
hawk and he says i'll get you back in the lunchbox
there actually is a vintage marvel superheroes
lunchbox with spider-man cap and thor on the front
fantastic four on the back and on the side scarlet
witch daredevil and yellowjacket wanted mistakes
using america's name when strange hadn't yet so
she drops the illusion that red hat is just as it
did when it warped the structures of west view and
wanda vision all of this coming from the darkhold
marvel's book of the damned which wandered from
the witch agatha harkness in one division this
whole dead landscape is likely near that mountain
cabin from the watervision post-credits scene all
the plants now rotting more and more as the dark
hole corrupts the landscape and actually in the
background of this burnt orchard are the ruins of
some structure that was probably what the large
house was when the illusion was up that structure
might be the cabin she was in in the one vision
post-credits scene wanda scarlett which wardrobe
has evolved since we last saw it in wanovision
scratches radiate from the heart region
showing how her fracturing of reality all stems
in the shape of vision's mind stone reflecting
how that heartbreak began when she had to
shatter her love's mind in infinity war
wanda says american sacrifice would be
but it's also essentially what defender strange
told america so when juana criticizes strange
for giving up the time stone and infinity war
so that thanos could render her heartbreaking
sacrifices revision pointless she's totally right
strange is a hypocrite that doesn't seem fair
this whole movie is a strange being's hold you
can't sacrifice people stop sacrificing people
sir you suck strange you always go too far
and you sacrifice your friends for the worst
stop it the worst of the universe you're
gonna sacrifice people i can sacrifice people
universe you're the worst what was the question
you posed yesterday oh about that realm like when
she drops the facade like where exactly are we i
mean the explanation that it's like corrupted due
to darkhold magic actually makes the most sense
to me because i was like are we still on earth
she dropped the facade it was like where on earth
looks like this and has a sun that big so the land
itself was corrupted by dark hole magic yeah
i guess so that's what i'm choosing to believe
wow damn dark cold dark hold of madness back at
commerce wong explains that the scarlet witch
was prophesied to either rule or annihilate
the cosmos recalling what agatha read from the
darkhold your power exceeds that of the sorcerer
supreme it's your destiny to destroy the world
commerce mounts its defenses master amir
returns to the 2016 film and we meet sarah
lightly based on wong's romantic partner of
sarah wolf in the comics in the minotaurs
also from the comics sorcerers from the hong
kong and london sanctums joined them remember the
2016 film established the three sanctums of earth
being in new york london and hong kong and behind
that one guy the portal to london has one of the
city's signatures because that always means a lot
and emerald city writings surrender dorothy and
smoke this being another witch demanding the magic
girl from another reality give herself a great
call damn this whole movie over the wizard of oz
the shots of them running along a brick road
defender strange being the brainless scarecrow
who ends up wobbling around puppeted our strange
the heartless tin man who cuts long the lion gets
his nerve the illuminati of course the great
and powerful oz ultimately proving to be total
christine glenda the good witch who ultimately
teaches strange that there is no place like his
home reality i mean the wizard of oz is one of
the coolest scariest and most visually invented
films of all time any multiverse movie is right
to follow its lead that time remy's just out
to make a good version of all the greater the
powerful see guys see wasn't my fault i could
have done it the way they wanted me i wanted to
do it but they made me do it sort of way let me
do it better here than over there just to prove
myself again i just wanted to remake wizard of oz
i promise not to take 10 years away from making
movies again that is a really great parallel
you know sometimes things sound like they're
reaching and anyone's breakdown or easter egg
video never us though if we ever theorize we're
always right on the money especially when it
came to this movie all 46 cameos came true that
actually sounds very plausible and that this is
uh part of the intention was sort of mapping it
around it yes it's wonderful i never thought of of
the wizard of oz through the lens of a multiverse
travel adventure but i think yes it's such a great
uh stand-in or a great sort of thing to swap out
because yeah even though you know you basically go
from reality to oz there's still all these other
places that look very unique inside of it and yeah
all the different characters matter and also about
strange doing a musical number about growing a
heart oh definitely yeah yeah that's interesting
and all the flying monkeys wanda probes the
camera's barrier and then finds a sneakier way
in by whispering into the mind of one sorcerer
similar to how she dismantled the avengers in age
of ultron by implanting visions in their temples
and just freaking them out she blasts the hell out
of kamartage all of its artillery and its archers
leaving one poor sorcerer in pain that she just
obliterates which seems cruel at first but the
guy was also in a lot of pain you could also
read as an act of mercy strange traps foreign
reality warping which his fingertips
have turned black the way agaves did
in juanavision when she used magic derived from
the dark hole they returned wipes and distorts
his shoots all this with the same claustrophobia
and external evil trying to break in that made the
evil dead so fun and like the possessed woman
there we only see the demon hands reaching up
to grab people which is also the kind of imagery
that you use to drag me to hell strange realizes
wanda's using reflective surfaces to get in and
as they rush to cover each mirror in puddle on
the first one that strange covers for just a few
frames remy sneaks in one of wanda's eyes glaring
returns to scare america and then her hand reaches
out through the gong as she crawls in i love that
shot so j horror yeah exactly or the grudge which
sam raimi produced the remake of absorbed and
weaponized and what if episode 4 and wanda begins
to drain america's power so strange dives into
america and they tumble through the multiverse and
it is insane this is the matter with three cloaked
heads these are the faces of the living tribunal
the ultimate legal cosmic entity in marvel lore
who oversees natural law of the multiverse with
three faces representing necessity equity and
revenge i like how here they are not on the same
head just three different heads maybe away this
universe in a fourth dimensional space shows
how they would look from a fourth dimensional
being in the infinity gauntlet comics the living
tribunal acquitted thanos for snapping away half
of all life and the infinity war writer said they
actually drafted a scene where strange and thanos
would have faced the living tribunal during their
wizard duel then they entered this country and
now you can just pass through them towards a great
source kind of looks like a mix of the celestials
world forge and eternals but i think we might be
seeing cerebro professor exodus oh cool connecting
with all the minds of mutants then they fall
through a freaking beehive filled with bees like
that what it was yeah okay i was wondering on
america's finger that first triggered her fear and
opened the star portals that took her moms from
her is this what the hexagons and the beekeeper
from one of vision were all about can someone
tell me please then they're underground baby
and some of those fish swim out with them back in
the open air new york where they pass taxis with
the ads grind house releasing which is a company
that remasters cult films that partnered with sam
raimi to restore the evil dead and it's run by
bob murray bob garrowski who also co yeah oh that
is awesome yes it's actually filled with stark
drones from spider-man far from home perhaps it's
the reality where they overthrew humanity then
a wow filled with bones true fire and brimstone
strange runs into a pile of skulls other skeletons
are climbing lampposts made out of spines all the
buildings are made of bones i mean i would say
this is just the mcu hill but this movie also
shows us like multiple possible hells and moon
knight did just explain that the mcu afterlives of
the egyptian underworld and the wakandan ancestral
plane are actually part of the same realm
just subjectively taking the form of whatever
the believer believes spoilers these various
hells might be part of that same belief-oriented
afterlife system next a universe with a t-rex
fighting a triceratops then an animated universe
with some goofy marching band music now this is
not exactly the animated style from what if and
they do pass that jonas and james sign so this is
actually the same spot where they fought gargantos
and this interesting reality with the wreckage of
some propeller plane with green flames i don't
know i thought maybe this could be the valkyrie
plane from the first cat film if it had made
it to its intended target of new york then
everything takes a cubic form i just love how the
break line between the blocks separates on the
teeth of strange's open mouth then they shift into
sloshing paint reality where america says she's
been trapped in before making it really hard to
eat then i love this an old-timey film desaturated
with wear on the celluloid showing 1930s new
york model t's the brooklyn bridge i love this
overhead this is the world that steve rogers and
bucky barnes grew up in then this interesting
alien setting that also looks a bit ancient
because it includes a stonehenge configuration
remember thor the dark world suggested
stonehenge was part of a coordinate layout
to triangulate the convergence maybe this is the
alien society who helped lay out those coordinates
then two more futuristic looking realities
then a rocky volcanic setting with lava rivers
looking a lot like the star wars universe
actually in a similar montage of what if
episode eight ultron infinity in the watcher that
also looked a lot like mustafar and they landed
thor ragnarok even had uh one of the star wars
jets that's what they call them right where's your
jet luke uh [__] like expert yeah well then it's
canon now yeah it's absolutely canon now how cool
would it be if they did manage to connect it to
star wars what this reminded me of because there's
been complaints of people saying like there's not
enough multiverse action in here like actually
going through the multiverse and i remember we
joked around when we saw the shortened version
of that clip it's going to be like x-men origins
wolverine where you see the trailer for origins
wolverine you go wow we're going to explore so
much then you realize it's just a quick montage
this did way more than origins wolverine but i
wasn't expected to be almost right about that like
oh yeah we may have to go to like two universes
yeah that montage is the thing that contains
the most like wow just imaginative craziness
like pointing out the details goes yo that was
cool but there's no way i anyone's taking away
emotional substance or context from it other than
look how cool that is yeah i want to spend five
minutes in each of these yeah why not but no i
was still in austin i still think it's beautifully
realized like every time you show watch i'm like
what is it so it's so good and in some ways i kind
of like the fact that if you slow it down you'll
get some more from it you know yeah that's what
canadian lad does so well yeah everything's
slow i watch this at point one percent point
and i learned nothing i learned that i could speed
this up a little bit and get the same amount of
context i learned that if you slow things down
enough everything sounds like whale song and they
land in dimension 838 a utopian manhattan covered
with plant life and wind turbines all built into
the skyscrapers the empire state building has
a waterfall coming from it this actually seems
like the direction 616 manhattan was going
in the mcu with far from home revealing a
new atrium constructed into the avengers tower and
various fantastic four hints at the ground level
all the advances of this reality were almost
certainly innovations of reed richards they're
on the roof of the 838 greenhouse and mound
where defender strangers buried back in 616.
said he had been on weird trips before of course
referring to the similar multiverse montage from
the 2016 film and the drugs all the citizens wear
monochromatic colors which might just be a hint of
the cold functionality of the society the emphasis
being on natural beauty over the artificial kind
of beauty of fashion and just visually for the
sequence it helps strange and america stick out
like sore thumbs here also a little detail
i thought was interesting if you look around
pretty much everyone is carrying an umbrella that
might be connected to those rainbow-colored clouds
overhead which might be an indicator that in this
universe rain and weather patterns are actually
artificially controlled scheduled on clockwork
coordinated by reed richards maybe by aurora
monroe storm as well a measure that they take to
help combat climate change ensure plant life is
properly hydrated and the people who live here
just kind of have to deal with rain being part
of their lives all the time of course the traffic
colors are reversed green for stop thus the x's
red for go thus the arrows now the fact that 838
proceeds on red when we would stop does foreshadow
how the foolish illuminati is going to proceed on
the scarlet witch they definitely should not our
man bruce campbell cameos sam raimi's star from
the evil dead films who came out in all three of
his spider-man movies and all those characters
were actually planned to be mysterio quinton
back i thought they were gonna go there i know
before sony canceled it here campbell's playing
pizza papa a vendor who sells pizza balls time
to deliver a pizza ball strange curses his hand
to punch himself in the face for three weeks a nod
to ash's cursed hand and evil dead two you see all
these things you were saying about earth 838 when
you elaborate more on what they could possibly
mean that really makes me feel like i missed out
on something to explore because you could be right
and whatever you're saying sounds accurate you
know like why do they all have umbrellas why
are those rainbow clouds does it have something
to do with that and the fact of this like color
coordination kind of evoking a sense that there's
a little kind of a judgmental society in in
certain ways yeah because you're talking about
like the coldness of the illuminati and i feel
like that would probably enhance the presentation
of when you do catch up with the illuminati of
understanding the society and the world that
they're at a little bit more just would have
been so awesome i would have loved that man not
now i'm not feeling this is supposed to enhance my
experience and it is but it's also making me wish
it was longer well yeah because the first thing
america says is like first of all multiversal
travels you don't know anything and i'm like
i want to learn a little bit about every one of
these worlds and the plot has to move so fast you
get the chance red means red means go yeah yeah
that's right i'm sorry pizza that's i apparently
exist on another earth why don't they exist here
a memory lane bank reveals the flashbacks of
christine giving steven that watch and america's
origin losing her mothers in the utopian parallel
but in the comics this was not america's fault
for even the bee's fault and really her mother
sacrificed themselves and ended up disintegrating
to becoming part of the universe but here in the
mcu it's hinted that her moms might still
be alive so they arrive at the 838 sanctum
and the statue of supreme strange which has been
built out into the street from the sidewalks the
cars have to go around it and i'll look at it and
pay respect the plaque reads dr steven strange
gave his life to feeding thanos we express eternal
gratitude to earth's mightiest hero earth's mighty
ciro of course the nickname for the avengers and
comics there's a rare book shop on the other side
of the street called mcleod's which could be a nod
to comics writer bob mccloud who co-created the
new mutants with chris claremont mordo 2016 film
strange says mordo dedicated his life to trying to
kill him referring to that movie's post-credit
scene where mordo turned against all sorcerers
too many never got to see any real conflict
between yeah i know it's consistent
projecting one's consciousness into one's
alternate self and over this raimi shows
cross-dissolving montages that one is ritual the
visuals evoke the dream sequence of rosemary's
baby there's surrealism superimposed shots
close-ups of the eyes and i love that symmetry
scores this with rock we hear some drums electric
guitar really this is the sound of witchcraft in
the 90s to me like the craft buffy the vampire
slayer i very much dig it every time i watch
that sequence i think of robert rodriguez
specifically oh good call yeah totally it's
exactly what rob rodriguez would do that like
moody rock and roll thing with the dissolves
you know mysterious such a rob rodriguez
motifs most of the the way this movie's
shot i immediately associate with other sam
bravey things i've seen that's the one time
i'm like oh a little bit of rodriguez in here
let rodriguez direct to marvel you coward
no do it do i do i want please i want him i'm
begging you marvel if he doesn't do a star wars
that's the price he won't do any more star wars
you can do some marvels don't do it already black
cat witchcraft but mordo drugged the tea with
green powder that also powers the cuffs called
the sands of nisanti a spell from the comics that
prevents the usage of magic for three minutes
wanda dreamwalks into another universe's west
view house the camera voyeuristically glides in
and peeks out from behind the staircase these
point of view shots evoking john carpenter's
opening shots of halloween the way wanda
creeps in here is very much like a stalker
a 1928 walt disney short called the skyscrapers
now walt disney made oswald shorts for universal
before contract dispute led to him launching
mickey mouse and steamboat willie so gasvald
has actually gained a cult following over
the years as the mickey who could have been
and i just love how he shows up here in this
alternate universe that's so cool i love that
even disney honored it the champion is still
frozen mid-spill the peas roll around on the
plate evoking the way the food squirmed around in
the kitchen in poltergeist an ocean churns in the
coffee cup an early sign of the incursions that
dream walking risks an ocean similarly crashed
through the post-incursion universe of sinister
strange and a dreamwalking one that takes control
of this wanda giving us this chilling moment
when elizabeth olsen looks directly at the camera
i see you i love it spooky horror trope that
we've seen in the closing shots of horror
films like psycho and paranormal activity
those shots are like ending shots though
yeah there's something that was so eerie about
in the middle of the movie when that happens
yeah absolutely like it's so striking it's spooky
so spooky in that moment i like to think that she
just popped out behind every audience member
whispered something in her ears get a refund
go to the bathroom refill your popcorn how'd you
like that avatar trailer sarah breaks wanda out of
this dreamwalking state by stabbing the darkhold
and sarah burns crying the love of wanda that's
why torturing and the others to get was actually
a copy of the spells carved into the walls of the
temple on mount wondergore which in the comics
is a place where the demon cafan inscribed the
spells that were eventually drafted into the
darkhold book this is also the mountain where in
some comics wanda and pietro are actually born
in the castle of the high evolutionary we got
a nod to that comic backstory in one division
with the sighting of bova milk boba being one
of the missionaries annie mintz wanted pietro
wundergore mountain is where cathodon initially
cursed wanda as a baby though in the 616 mcu want
a vision established that she was born to arena in
oleg maximoff in sokovia though in that flashback
wanda showed she already had as a girl low-level
probability hex capabilities so it remains to be
seen if the mcu will trace that back to catholic's
curse or if they're going to define wanda as a
mutant or both wong takes wanda to that temple all
of their carves to look exactly like the scarlet
witch page of the dark old that we saw in juan
division episode nine this temple's guarded by
hulking creatures that may be based on the ingary
catholics elders spawn minions from the comics
but when they take a knee wanda realizes that
the chamber isn't a tomb but a throne doesn't
wong directly say at one point like this is
something catholic though though it's a line
that's kind of easy to miss for some reason
i didn't catch it all the first time i watched
it i i did but i feel like it is right after a
moment that maybe is like a crowd expositionally
explaining what's on the wall i do wish these uh
minions actually did something in the movie you
know they threw a rock at wong it was like it was
good rock though they subverted expectations by
bowing is there's a dark hole in the 838 universe
can that wanda also become a scarlet witch you
guys are gonna tell me no because scott which is
the nexus being but they don't talk about nexus
beings at all in this movie so yeah it's like
is this wanda the only scarlet witch and the rest
are just wandas with slider powers and where's one
other wanda's husband he's drunk at the bar yeah
the universe is deadbeat vision normal human yeah
office dad worker in the first episode of water
in this universe vision was based on windows 7
technology instead of ultron technology so he's
really lagging the altar she stands on is actually
carved with that same horned head figure as we saw
on the dark hold cover this is perhaps the horned
form of cathode from the comics meanwhile variant
christine explains that they are in dimension 838
and she has designated strange's home universe
as 616. 616 is the numerical designation of the
primary universe in the comics and until now the
mcu has really been considered earth 19999 based
on a joke by kevin feige that he planned for the
mcu to run for that many years but now it is first
codified as 616 which was hinted at in
the tva's film strip in loki episode one
and an easter egg on a storage locker and end
game and interestingly mysterious line from far
from home there are multiple realities peter
this is earth dimension 616. i'm from earth
833. now quentin bank was lying in that moment he
was reciting a script written by guterman so it's
just another uncanny coincidence they chose the
correct numerical bits of multiverse travelers
gooder mint origins now christine compares 616
steven to 838 steven using his hand injuries a
kind of multiversal fingerprint so like for peter
parker losing a parent figure and the with great
power quote are absolute constants for those
variants their hand injuries are the constant
and on that screen you can see stephen
cell is d23 which is a disney easter egg
walt disney founded his animation studio
christine says that this is the baxter
foundation and not of course to the baxter
building but actually a fantastic four in
the comics strange speculates that this could be
part of the avengers or shield or hydra hydra was
an organization that was tracking strange since
2014's captain america winter soldier what targets
you bruce banner steven strange anyone who's a
threat that being the first time we're at stephen
strange mission in the mcu but mordo declares
the illuminati we'll see you now the illuminati
in the marvel comics is a six-member group of
leaders representing different super factions
you got tony stark leader of the avengers charlton
xavier leader mutant kind reed richards leader of
the fantastic four doctor strange sorcerer
supreme black bolt leader of the inhumans
and neymar king of atlantis as is the case here
though their meddling often gets in their own way
serving the illuminati are these ultron sentries
which are actually voiced by actor ross marquan
who voiced what if in red skull in infinity
war now the baxter foundation agency master
impressionist 838 manhattan and the interior is
modeled on the lobby of the british museum of
london mordo introduces the 838 illuminati lineup
including himself naming himself baron carl mordo
the character's name from the comics strange
dodge is the union jack shield of captain carter
leader of the 838 avengers played by hayley atwell
looking just as she does and what if so presumably
there are other avengers in this 838 universe then
there's captain marvel maria rambo defender of the
cosmos lashana lynch returning from the 2019
captain marvel film presumably from a history
where maria not carol danvers was irradiated
by that lightspeed engine then black agar
leader of the inhumans and keeper of the terrigen
mist on some mountain reprises the royal from
abc's short-lived inhuman series now in humans are
superpower genetic experiments created by the cree
who live on the moon black bolts voice releases
a powerful sonic blast so the guy rarely talks
here he's seen with this tuning fork headgear
from the comics terrigen miss meanwhile is the
kree technology that creates inhumans via cocoon
we actually saw this process quake in agents of
shield intelligent mist may tie into miss marvel
since that is how kamala khan gets her powers in
the comics though the disney plus series may be
going in a different direction then of course
reed richards aka the elastic mr fantastic
of the fantastic four played by fan cast
dreamboat john krasinski i like how he teleports
in via the square portal which is a completely
new kind of tech that we've seen in the mcu it
seems very much like the kind of tech richards
and dr doom used in the comics it does fascinate
me though i do believe there were supposed to be
seven people on the illuminati seat and i've
seen photos that are like the illuminati who's
who's sitting there and i count seven chairs um
i've seen cause there's only six right now yeah
so who's the seventh i'm like there's ultron
bots so if there's ultron that must mean there
was an iron man who created ultron and part of
this like trimmed down from two hours and 40
to two hours and reshooting did they cut out an
iron man cameo would they do that to tom cruise
it just seems so weird like i can't figure out
what the point would be taking him out if they
shot that even if people had heard you know the
rumors flying around or whatever it's still one
of those things where it's like you don't confirm
it people are still going to lose their minds were
they just misleading us normally it's put less
people in there and then when they watch the movie
there will be more yeah it's like put more in
there and then watch it there's gonna be one less
that's the new irony is that they're gonna
market us with something way more broad looking
and they give us something a lot
more don't take notes from sodie
strahange asks if the fantastic four quote
charted in the 60s of course comparing them
to the beatles like the way bruce banner talked
about the avengers infinity war broke up like a
band like like the beatles and the way toby and
andrew thought the avengers was a band and no
way home well you don't have the avengers is that
a bad are you in a band now strange is probably
just joking but ant-man director peyton reed did
pitch doing a fantastic four movie set in the 60s
like the beatles movie a hard day's night and
many of us have speculated that the fantastic
four could have existed in the 60s of the 616
mcu and the quantum realm the way that yeah
the fantastic four and hank pym ant-man all kind
of work together now reed explains that strange's
arrival at 838 risks an incursion which is
determined marvel comics for when universes
collide like a series of incursions between earth
cycloid worlds 1610 the universe of miles morales
is what led to the 2015 secret wars event when
all these variant heroes and villains met in dr
doom's battle world which is why many believe that
the mcu might be headed toward a similar event in
a fifth avenger's crosstalk so cool which in this
case might be kang the conqueror because we saw
what may have been incursions in the mcu in this
minute's intro video in loki episode one and kevin
feige just confirmed that loki and silvi killing
that kang variant he who remains led to the sacred
timeline unraveling into various incursions and
that's really what set the stage for the crisis of
this movie and remember the original kang variant
nathaniel richards was a 31st century descendant
of reed richards so really this is all connected
oh [__] i totally forgot about that yeah at the
time of watching loki i remember that but damn
that is so true ah that makes it even cooler yes
loki does figure it it does make it even cooler
holy [__] i love that it's a damn good breakdown
this is a great breakdown second viewing made me
appreciate it that much more now this is making
me appreciate it that that that much more so how
come the spider-man stuff didn't create incursions
oh no no that stuff was allowed to happen because
of the situation that happened in loki which was
an ultimate incursion the tva can't
cause incursions for some reason
yeah i don't know are they like neutrally charged
in the multiversal scheme of things where if like
they show up anywhere they're just not gonna
have an effect it doesn't seem as though but
i don't know so many questions yes what about
like an infinity war when they literally go to
another universe that doesn't cause an incursion
incursions happen when kevin feige says that
what you're doing you never have and of course
the sixth member of this illuminati floats in
professor charles xavier with patrick stewart
returning for the fox x-men franchise we should
tell him the truth but rather than the exact
character from those films which do have their
own convoluted timeline in which charles dies
in logan this charles has a yellow hover chair a
green suit the blue and black tie looking exactly
as he does in the 90s animated series actually if
you listen closely the music of this moment is
ron wasserman's theme music from that series
also when they introduce captain carter they
bring in alice of estries captain america theme
now there is one more chair that's left empty on
this illuminati daisy suggesting some past seventh
member or just an extra chair that they keep open
now those ultron centuries kevin feinstein's very
iron man since it was i talked too soon mcu again
in the comics it was hank pym who created ultron
so that seventh seat could be his what if hank pym
was there the whole time it was just for him yeah
he was like i'm just gonna sit back and observe
him yeah i'm not gonna jump in he don't even
also in the comics the illuminati originally
reached out to t'challa the black panther who
ended up deciding not to join the group that
might be his seat and the ultron sentries are
just created by reed richards so they finally
revealed the truth that during their infinity
war conflict with thanos 838 steven used
the dark hole to try to find a solution
in the multiverse but in doing so accidentally
caused an incursion that killed everyone in that
alternate universe now reed does say that 838
stephen never told them the details so there's
probably more to that backstory now charles
uses this telepathy to thank goodness show
not tell taking this to the day they beat thanos
using the book of ashanti look closely at thanos
corpse yikes his double-bladed uber blade is
broken and plunged into his chest and importantly
his gauntlet does not yet have all the stones
we see the power stone space stone reality stone
and soul stones but the mind stone is missing
which tells us that vision may still be alive
in eight three eight eight three eight strange's
fingers so is that fishing big and wonderful
just like we saw on the fingers of wanda in
agatha black volt whispers i'm sorry i like
how his voice echoes louder and louder with onson
mount recording multiple versions of this line
building up to a complete shout out to schoolway
showing how that sonic blast obliterates strange
wanda uses the darkhold temple to dreamwalk into
838 wanda's house i like that little detail of her
this knocking over to us that in the 838 dimension
wanda had that perfect life with billy and tommy
so the mind stone being missing from thanos's
gauntlet and vision survival might have been
the key difference there so this possessed wanda
attacks the baxter foundation and charles tells
stephen to get to the book of ashanti and he says
just because someone stumbles and loses their way
doesn't mean they're lost forever which is a
direct quote from 2014's x-men days of future
past when charles said this line to his younger
self just because someone stumbles loses their way
it doesn't mean they're lost forever now that
movie ended with charles in his first hover chair
we saw in live-action film so who knows maybe
that restored timeline from days of future past
didn't lead to logan it could have led to this and
then after finishing off oh fascinating in their
oil like it is blood recalling that dark moment
and age of ultron when she ripped out ultron's
heart and just let it bleed that oil the oil
streaks on her face totally evokes sissy's basic
and carrying it totally influences the blood bath
water unleashes here also the way her hand bursts
out of the darkness later in her mind reminding
us of brian de palma's final shot of that movie
so why did it why didn't wanna
grab some shoes in the way yeah
her feet are in pain a lot in this fight i'm
like a couple pairs of tennis shoes might have
done the trick for you maybe even some slippers
she was just finished watching moon night
she was like i know i'm going to get
into some trouble here i can you know
walk around on the glass and really feel the
the penance for what i'm about to do you know
it's all connected she should have grabbed
some shoes it doesn't make me 40 minutes later
most dad joke i've heard something hey it took
only 40 minutes to get here reed says that he
has children of his own and that their mother
is alive referring to susan storm the invisible
woman and their children franklin richards and
valeria richards and confirming that lineage
that will one day lead to nathaniel richards kang
wanda erases black bolt's mouth like neo in the
matrix and folks this is the most horrific death
we have seen in the mcu and i hate to do this but
we gotta go through it here just think
about it black bolt does not have to scream
the guy spends most of his time not at all using
his vocal cords but it's just the panic of his
mouth being erased that rattles him to his core
so he ends up making the worst possible mistake of
vocalizing anything that scream ricochets around
his jaw you can see it glowing on the other side
i did not notice that
holy [__] i thought water just blew his head up
oh no no no no i didn't catch all the
details but yeah it was clear like oh
damn he just tried to say something and his
head exploded i didn't i thought wanda did
that directly to him because like the very next
moment she like makes him all like silly string
oh wow that's so cruel i know you guys are
like crooked i don't know for the first time
what pay attention whatever it's cool to see it
now we're on the same page jerks canadian lad i
know you're in the comments watching this
watch this at 0.25 speed i would've done
excuse me projectionist oh canadian lad you
should do that oh my god and then right out
of theater guys i'm here for do you like
what soups does we got an early screening
for thor love and thunder but it's going to be
special we're going to watch this is 0.25 street
then reed makes the mistake of attacking and
wanda unravels his elastic body into ribbons
and then pops his head like a pinata so then
peggy and maria jump in peggy using jetpack
thrusters that she presumably got from reed
peggy spits out some blood and then quotes
cap's iconic line of i can do this all day but
then poor peggy gets severed at the midsection
by your own shield actually if you look closely
after that shield goes through peggy is still
initially in one piece but as the camera refocuses
on the shield in the foreground her blurry form in
the background slumps forward but in two halves
and then one it collapses a statue and that's
a bloody shield that first strike i mean each of
these four actors must have been directed on how
to emote their own deaths but there is no way
all these actors were on set with each other or
told how each other would die because they should
be screaming and horror otherwise these four must
be pretty desensitized to people dying this way
charles enters want his mind that's a good point
it's a white void where he's able to walk he was
a black turtleneck and beyond that door is a pile
of rubble including a tv set playing the intro
to one division episode one air sirens raid in
this revels clearly the rebel that wanda and
pietro were buried under in sokovia when stark
warhead landed in their home but the scarlet
witch's red cloud closes in and she snaps
his neck making this the third time we have
had to see patrick stewart charles xavier died
now let's do it two more times scarlet witch who
does not care who she hurts that she tries to be
with her kids are block points inspired directly
by the house of m comic event but whereas that
story goes deeper and deeper into x-men lore make
some major moves on whether or not they even exist
in reality this movie's connections to mutant
kind stop right here i did have a thought earlier
today you know how x-men the last stand tried
redoing x-men the last stand with dark phoenix
i would like them down the road which seems even
more likely because mcu is all connected i think
scarlet witch elizabeth wilson is so awesome in
this movie brilliant in this movie it would be
cool to like do a more faithful house of m because
she's the ultimate threat to like everyone she
could rewrite like all of reality you know yeah
and so it would be cool to really get the epic
showdown of everyone after you know scarlet witch
hey 30 years down the line i feel like we probably
will start seeing like specific runs adapted
maybe yeah but do a good version not that dark
phoenix [__] you know like a good one no just
keep remaking dark phoenix until it's good and
that's why i don't think they could have done that
now because it probably would have made everyone
think of kind of dark music like yeah that's the
problem like oh woman gone crazy who was once hero
we must defeat her so strange american christine
flee as wanda chases them her eyes glowing red
looking a lot like her zombie form from those
episodes of what if they find the hatch the
waypoint in the book of ashanti but it is locked
requiring a special key strange's wristwatch give
them to him by christine another absolute element
shared by all strangers so they get to the book of
ashanti in the gap junction but wanda attacks and
a page from the book burns out showing a star if
you look closely so remember the dark hold page
showed the scarlet witch this book shows america
chavez's symbol proof that the girl was destined
to be the perfect antidote to the dark sorcery
of the scarlet witch and strange sees this page
burn which is how he knows what to tell america
in that final act strange about how it banished to
a post-incursion universe which slowly melts that
melty and looking a lot like the way reality
eroded and what if episode four after strange
broke an absolute point and they passed the
floating honey beige 1973 oldsmobile delta 88 this
same car sam raimi puts it oh yeah gordon told
me ben's car spider-man movies and appeared in
the evil dead series and it dragged me to hell now
you'll notice this incursion universe has two red
streaks racing through it the same color as that
looming crescent shape beyond the sanctum stairway
now kids what are crescents crescents of course
are formed by the shadow of the earth on the moon
from the light of the sun behind us so i wonder
if this crescent could be this dead world's shadow
being cast on the other world that collided into
it maybe earth 838 the reality fascinating strange
that collided in this universe the dimension of
sinister strange that could have been the unseen
annihilation that the illuminati referred to 838
strange might have used a dark hole to dreamwalk
into sinister strange and sinister strange tried
to cast him out and that war between the two
dragged their worlds together in a way that killed
everyone in sinister strange's universe that could
been the war that he lost that he was talking
about and the guilt over winning that war might
have been what 838 strange confessed to the rest
of the illuminati and now these two streaks might
represent the lifelines of those two universes
synced forever parallel but never touching yet
still way too close man you know they need to do
like some star wars animated [__] you know that
just like [__] just explains all this stuff in
all of the gaps dives into all of it in animated
show format that'd be cool dude a supplemental
multiverse of madness animated series please
right how awesome would that be yeah they call
it what it is i mean to be fair and what if
every episode started dr strange you know one
that's like specifically a fill in the timeline
you know i would i would love that i would adore
that yeah do it do it i mean the creepiest detail
about this place is the fact that a freaking
field of bones stretches in front of the sanctum
everyone in this reality died from an incursion
but no human remains are visible anywhere else
that means that these unfortunate souls of this
universe led to the sanctum looking for sanctuary
begging this strange to save him and he watched
as they died strange brings up their dead sister
donna whom he says fell in the ice when they were
kids in the comics donna drowned after getting a
cramp in a swimming pool i feel like that's a line
that kind of flies over people's heads a lot to me
to me the great and all-powerful greg alba
as i have named myself legally by law i've
submitted the papers is that when he says that
because it's like such a specific detail that's
obviously supposed to be like okay this must be
a real doctor strange but i took it as like this
is a more personal motive that he still holds on
to and that's why he's so intent on like saving
america chavez is part of redemption for that
because it happened at a young age a little girl
said something about frozen lake star looks kind
of ice frozen i don't know that's like the kind
of [__] you would say eric yeah you go frozen
invoking the frozen stars trying to protect his
new surrogate little sister yeah falling through
the frozen ice the multiverse yeah yeah i was
just trying to think like you and you're not even
saying that yeah what gives you we paying you for
yeah man we pay you to like marvel marvel's right
marvel pays you the right mark sinister strange
reveals a third eye on his forehead now strange
sometimes has the third eye in the comics as a
manifestation of the eye of agamotto a way of
showing the mystical sight that the ancient one
referred to when she touched this spot on his head
open your eye oh yeah but in this case the third
eye represents the twisted evil of the darkhold
the curse of kathan living on these two strangest
duel sinister strange's sorcery is purple the
same color of agatha's magic the color of the dark
dimension and dormammu which is something that's
going to play a very big role as dormammu's niece
clea shows up in the post-credits scene to work
with a stranger with three eyes during the fight
strange grabs the piano making that same horror
music sting that up until now in this movie has
meant fear but instead now he weaponizes the
fear to lift the music notes off the page
interpretation i love this music duel so
much swedish restraints blocks the notes by
conjuring the five lines of a scale which is how
you would contain loose notes and sheet music
and forming the new arrangement which plays
as johan sebastian bach's famous organ cords
strange impaling them on the fence like saruman
but the third eye still opens because the evil
lives so strange now uses the dark hole to
dreamwalk into the one strange still left in
616 the buried defender strange resurrecting the
corpse now remember earlier wong told wanda that
no sorcerer can pass the barrier to winogor temple
so those souls of the dam that attack defender
strange are not just an obstacle using them by
turning them into a new cloak is literally the
only way strange could fly over there that's just
a really smart example of what screenwriters call
economy of story repurposing story elements we
thought were just set dressing or characterization
or raised stakes like the defender strange
corpse the watch strange scene a star page
in the book of ashanti these souls of the
damned and instead giving them new practical
functions for the hero to advance so when a bunch
of nerds in your movie theater started applauding
in this moment going yes it isn't just because
we love sam raimi's zombie [__] i mean we do
it's because this moment was a culmination of
all these seeds that were planted throughout
the movie it's true we were all like
economy of story good writing techniques
yeah man there's a lot of good good economical
choices made well i think that is a great point
because how many times did we see zombie strange
or reanimated strange in the trailers like so much
and both times i watch it i'm not even thinking
about it yeah right the first time i watched it i
completely forgot that could happen or supposed
to come or whatever yeah and so when it starts
zooming in on the plot you're like oh here we go
oh yeah what christine says to him you know there
need to be a strange alive on your earth and then
strange goes who said anything about being alive
yeah both times i'm like oh yeah yeah it's such a
rewarding uhly executed moment now when the souls
of the damned attacks christine she banishes them
with the breezier of bomb goliath the same article
you don't know how to use that do you ah
oh crap yeah that thing could have banished him
to hell strange arrives with the damned soul cape
and wanda says dreamwalking you hypocrite the
same thing kaiselius shouted at the ancient one
when she used dark dimension magic hypocrite now
realizing america's power is needed to beat wanda
strange repeats this is the only way so once
again we have looped back to the opening scene
a defender strange must once again face this
moral quandary of sacrificing america this is
what stream writing calls coming full circle
coming full circle choice what's changed what
makes this strange different well this strange
trusts america to control her own power because
every portal she opened in this film has brought
them to where they needed to go remember this is
the same strange who looked at 14 million 65
paths and found the one correct path for his
life and so unlike all the other strangers who
are always seeking a better life including 838
strange who looked in a different universe for
one our strange finally realizes he has gratitude
for the path that he is on because folks the true
ideal of america is not the pursuit of happiness
it's gratitude for what we have so america punches
wanda first into hell wow i love that that's where
she thinks she needs to go but america learns
that the better destination for wanda is just
to give the woman what she wants her west view
home where her sons actually see her true nature
now based on the other wandest bruises this is
actually 838 the same wanda that she possessed
earlier and you'll see how now on the tv is
snow white in the seven dwarves remember in the
alt universe there is an alt universe walt
disney short starring oswald a lucky rabbit
but in this one it's the iconic walt disney first
feature length animated film snow white and seven
dwarves also remember a story with an evil witch
queen that haunted me as a little kid so these
boys are on pins and needles about an evil witch
queen coming into a portal into their living room
yeah it's all great like metaphors and [__] but
really i was taken away is that these kids just
have a really unproductive unhealthy lifestyle
wanda just feeds them like sugary fatty foods
they sing a song about wanting to get ice cream
and they're just like sat on the couch watching
tv all goddamn day yeah i'm just arguing about
baseball like read a book read a comment to the
children of wanda and visionary go do something
extraordinary guys you guys are some lazy ass
there's some average ass kids outside play
catch you know develop your super speed and
witchy power always eating like such shitty like
the last time i saw you guys you were getting like
fancy ass sweets in the kitchen and now you want
ice cream and wanda like there's an upstairs
you can get some privacy sister all you do watch
tv with her yes this is the universe where she
doesn't have to do anything she doesn't even have
to leave the house ever she just is with them
while they watch tv and despite being possessed
into doing horrible things this other wanda
forgives the scarlet witch assuring her that these
boys will be loved telling the mother what she
needs to hear and so wanda collapses the temple
on herself i forgive you for murdering everyone
and hijacking my body wanda may be dead we do
still have this other wanda who was there for all
the craziest [__] that happened in this movie
awanda who remember shares this 838 reality with
mutants with the fantastic four so some version
of the house of m no more mutants moment may be
on the way in the mcu but that opens the question
yes could she also be a scarlet witch yeah can
there just be infinite numbers of this nexus being
doing no more mutants and stuff yeah because if it
is on the way that would mean this wanda would
have the abilities of the scarlet witch to do
no more mutants even though they wiped out like
you know the main ones of the illuminati well yeah
the question to me then would be is there another
way for her to achieve that without the dark hold
steroids wanda just becomes an addict you're
shooting up on her butt yeah yeah tommy billy's
watch tv you're huge you gotta slow down bob this
isn't chaos magic wanda these horses take these
in the final scenes of this movie strange gets
closure with christine he leaves america in
training at camertaj and finally gives sorcerer
supreme wong the bow he deserves and most
importantly he finally fixes the broken watch
the camera transitioning from the broken lens
to clarity but that clear vision proves itself
a curse in the final shot of the film the man is
seen too well with three eyes as the curse of the
darkhold lives on it's a scarlet letter for his
sins and a new unhealable wound for the surgeon to
suffer now i break down the most credited scenes
in another video and we got lots of multiverse
madness videos coming down the pipeline so
subscribe for more takes on this insane film
and hey if you live in the san francisco bay
area i'm back performing comedy live with endgames
improv at the stage where it's cool my first show
coming saturday may 14th then after that every
other saturday at the same space coming out with
improv reactions follow me on instagram
and twitter we're moving to san francisco
and subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for watching bye
that was a good ass breakdown good
lovely wonderful [__] no you're wrong
they said that wanda destroyed all the darkholds
yeah the other universe yeah that's why you
asked the question you're not wrong that's why
you're opposing the question i'm right i'm wrong
i cannot accept this we must fight to the death
we must duel i don't i gotta find another universe
where i'm right there's 14 billion possibilities
i found the one reality all right guys thanks
for being here eric you killed it man you
editors you did an okay job it's all eric
yeah good job only to error only to eric the other
guys you might need to reconsider finding you
yeah get out of here with this yeah
man because it's not looking pretty
for you i find a multiverse where
your skills are better appreciated
no you guys are just kidding
no crazy job seriously that's
good we're just being satirical anyway we'll see
you guys soon much love to everyone including me